what do you think about what do you
think about what he was doing
because he was going finding homeless
people saying that he needed to fill out
they need to fill out surveys get their
social security numbers like
matt's a megalomaniac that's what
enabled matt to do the things that he
did
plain and simple he's a narcissistic
megalomaniac that he just
you know you know
that little governor that people have
inside of him
that tells them not to do certain things
or not to talk to people a certain way
matt doesn't have that
yeah he doesn't have that governor he
doesn't have that filter i'm all better
now though no i mean but what do you
think about like
that's the actual process that he had to
go through
i wouldn't to steal people's identity i
couldn't i would never do that
if that's what i had to do it seems like
so much work compared to what you were
are you kidding me
there's no way there's no way i wouldn't
there's no way i would never in a
million years
ever do something like that i would
break it i would
you know do a a commercial burglary and
get into a [ __ ] file system or
something like that before
i even thought to do something like that
well i have to do a survey you just walk
around the pad you just hey excuse me
i'm taking you know you're just i'm
walking through what are you saying
and you get twenty dollar bill you say i
gotta i'm doing surveys i'll give you
twenty dollars
we're trying to figure out where we want
to put the next uh we say american cross
no right no next time how do i go home
just home you can say homeless facility
but yeah
the salvation army yeah salvation army i
had a badge and i'd asked myself how
many people actually gave you the real
information he said all of them all of
them almost
i literally i'll bet you i'll bet you
maybe maybe one
or two people gave me something bad
almost never
and even then like i had one guy who
gave me
his his his uh date of birth he gave me
was off
like he switched like he i was in free
he was gonna fool me i'm gonna change my
date of birth
it doesn't matter when we pulled the
credit the real date of birth showed up
but that's
that's a super inefficient way of
stealing somebody's identity well it's
actually
because these people are [ __ ]
homeless junkie drug addicts yeah
they're not going to show up it was
creative
let's say they're not going to show up
and say hey they're never going to show
up to court
they're not going to know if somebody's
doing anything with their name or
anything like that because
they're [ __ ] crazy and homeless yeah
the bank's not going to call them and
say hey somebody's using your credit
card
it's more work right and it's less
efficient than what i was doing i mean
obviously my work more money though i'm
borrowing a million dollars and there's
also a different scam though yeah
completely different you know
when i stole people's identities i
wasn't you doing it to
for any kind of financial gain like i
wasn't using their name to
build a credit report or take loans out
or going to a bank or anything like that
right
i was just using it so that and when i
went to go do my dirt that people didn't
know who i was like say i was going to
open a ups store box at a ups store
that's when i would make an identity or
i was going to do like an hq
you know like the virtual office or
whatever you're designing to cover your
tracks
exactly yeah yeah yeah what about what
about eventually
of what i mean you know i don't know if
i mean i don't know if you want me to
help you along here oh of course yeah so
eventually
you end up you're in you were went to
rock hill
rock hill south carolina yeah where you
get
pinched right so that [ __ ] backwater
hick-ass town i should have never
[ __ ] where was it
south carolina rock hill south carolina
yes sir yes sir them [ __ ] rednecks
why were you there unbelievable the the
girl i was with at the time that's where
she was from she's from south carolina
her family's from there
and a little southern belle yeah and for
whatever reason we decided to leave
florida and
take my son and go to south carolina i'm
like listen i can do what i do anywhere
right you know what i mean so you know
we get up there and that that was the
nail in the coffin
event that that was the nail in the
coffin that's what sent me to prison was
was
eventually was my decision yeah that was
it
so how did that play out um
right so when i when you when you send
out when i send out packages
um i just go to a ups store and i i
cause
i pre-print my labels so i just go to a
ups store and i hand it to them and give
them five dollars and they scan it they
send in the outgoing mail and it goes
out
you know which is cool because in south
florida there's ten thousand [ __ ] ups
stores i mean you literally put in your
gps and you get
all day long yeah they're everywhere so
i never have to go to the same one twice
and i could do this for months and
months and months and keep rotating
well where i was there was two ups
stores
and that was it so i had to go to the
same ups store to send out my packages
when i was sending them out
the same eps store same epsor so
eventually the old man
that was running the ups store i didn't
know at this time that
they're all franchises i mean i know
that i knew that i didn't know that
so the old man that worked at the ups
store was the owner
of the ups store and i was going there
you know
three four times a week sending [ __ ] out
and they're going all over the world my
shit's going to
you know europe south america the
documentary chick
right yeah so pretty much the old man um
was just a
a nosey old [ __ ] he couldn't you know
what i mean so i
dropped the package off one day and he
opened it and went through it
and seen what i was sending out and then
he called the postmaster general and
then the postmaster general contacted
the secret service
he he also keep in mind he didn't he's
walking in all tattooed up this is a
little towel oh you had the tattoos
yeah yeah this is a little town in south
carolina he
thought he was sipping drugs driving a
nice cadillac yeah he thought he's
sipping drugs
anyway this uh [ __ ] crazy old dude
who worked at a ups store yeah he cut up
on your package found your credit card
yeah he uh contacted the
postmaster general postmaster general
contacted the secret service and then
um i got an email one day telling me i
had a package waiting on me
which i did actually um i had you know
stuff coming in and out and uh
i get there and i i walk up to the
counter and i'll give the old man points
for this one
i'll give the old [ __ ] bastard points
for this one because
i couldn't tell he was not even shook
really he played it cool as
[ __ ] cucumber when i went up
there i signed for my package it was
just like normal it was like an everyday
you know what i mean transaction with
them and i'm pretty good like i pick up
on subtle things like that i can tell if
somebody's nervous i can tell if
something isn't right
yeah you know especially when i deal
with somebody on a regular basis but no
he played it cool
i'm going to walk out the door and the
door swings open
and i didn't see the dude's face i just
seen a badge because he had it on his
belt
they were in like plain clothes and he
had a badge on his belt and that's what
i seen
and then i went to go walk out the door
and the other dude blocked the door and
i was like [ __ ]
and that's when it all just came that's
when it just came flooding like my
stomach [ __ ] dropped
like i immediately my armpits just
started like turned on the faucets you
know what i mean like the [ __ ] nerves
just started going crazy
and they were like ryan pearson and i
was like yeah
and he said uh what do you say he said
uh
um we need to talk to you about what
you've been sending out of here
i tried i tried to play stupid at first
but he said ryan pearson so i was like
okay well obviously he doesn't know who
the [ __ ] i am
and i tried to play stupid at first i
was like what do you mean he's like he
gave me that look and i was like
all right all right he's like well why
don't you come in the back he's like
come in the back cause there were people
coming in on the store and she's like
what's coming back and talk to us real
quick
so i i sat down he's like uh they're
like so what have you been sending out
of here because he's like we have your
package you sent out here we know what
you've been sending out of here
and then that's when literally the movie
blow flashed in my head
and i remember when he was sitting and
you seen the movie blow obviously when
he's sitting in the room and um
and and he knew it was a setup at that
time he's like he knew it he just sat
back in his chair and he was like
all right [ __ ] it let's do it and that's
what i said
i said i was like all right [ __ ] it
let's do it he's like what's your name i
was like you know john boziak and then
he's like would you be sending out here
i was like credit cards
he's like all right and then he's like
you know i had to explain to him
what i had been doing and of course i
minimized every [ __ ] thing you know
what i mean i minimized the [ __ ] out of
that situation
i was like okay in my mind i was like
what do they have
you know what i mean what do they what
do they really have right 500 cards
okay that's what they have so
i gave them i i was i gave them
what they've what i kind of felt like i
already knew they they thought they knew
that i didn't know that they knew
if that makes any sense you know what i
mean like i was trying to be slick with
it
and so i just told them i gave i fed
them what they what i thought they were
like okay they know i've been making
cards so i'm going to tell them out of
making cards i'm not going to [ __ ]
tell them how long i've been doing it
right
or how much i'm you know how many cards
i've been doing and obviously i'm not
going to just be like okay
here it is i've been doing everything
you know and i'm not going to obviously
i'm not going to tell him myself
so i just i gave him enough to set that
i felt like satisfied him
so i agreed to um he gets on the phone
with his supervisor he's on the phone
on and off he's got blackberries he's
sent an email he's making phone calls
what year is it now 2009. okay
and uh yeah he's in the blackberry
crackberry
yeah those are blackberries well all the
feds use blackberry i think they still
use iphones
oh do they yeah they're all iphones now
but yeah they're back yeah they used the
blackberries back in the day so um was i
saying
oh yeah i agreed to um i agreed to let
them come
to my uh my home in search and um
seize all my equipment oh yeah so see
the list
of the seizure list like when i got it
yeah it's
multiple freedom of information yeah
yeah well and it's on your indictment no
no
yeah it's on the internet it's on my
indictment yeah where they list like
i was just you know this fargo or this
thermal printer this thermal printer
this
like multiple mrs it's like three or
four laptops i mean just it just goes on
and on and on and on like
um you know hot foil you know press
machine but you know it's like
like why do you here's what [ __ ] blew
me away out of this whole situation
is i they didn't arrest me i didn't go
to jail
they fingerprinted me and took my
picture out they fingerprinted me in the
back of the ups door then they made me
go out in front of the ups door
and they made me stand and they took my
picture and they turned aside and they
took my picture
and then they they had a bunch of
paperwork faxed to the ups store and i
signed all of it letting them okay i
give you permission to search my home i
give you permission to
you know whatever this is before we even
went to my condo they put me in the back
of their car
drove me to my condo and they went in
and they spent about four and a half
hours
tearing that [ __ ] apart just two
dudes actually was one dude
that was doing all the searching i was
sitting in the living room and the other
dude was just sitting in there with me
you know and to these guys i'll give
these guys credit they were cool you
know i mean like
under any other circumstances like these
weren't like bad dudes like some cops
are [ __ ] pricks
right you know what i mean they just
they talk down to you they talk [ __ ] to
you you know what i mean they tear your
[ __ ] up
you know what i mean these [ __ ]
were kind of cool you know i mean they
were in my closet i had like
like 300 pairs of sneakers or something
like that and the dude was like he was
like so he kept coming out there's like
dude i really like your [ __ ] he's
like weird you're talking about like
jordan's and she's talking about my
sneaker collection while this other
[ __ ] was in there [ __ ] tearing up
and going through my computers and [ __ ]
and then so yeah they searched my whole
place they they confiscated um
anything with a removable removable
storage i think they say anything with
removable storage
they took it so any hard drive any cell
phone um
laptops they obviously they took i had a
safe in the bedroom
i had my safe in the bedroom with a
bunch of money in it [ __ ] ammunition
[ __ ] i had like like a thousand cards
or something like that
printed because what i would do is i
would get ahead of myself like if i
would
was wasn't busy i would be bored i would
just print and make a thousand cards
just in case you got any blanks right
just to stick them in the safe and then
i would just and then if i needed to i
would go ahead and boss them and coat
them
and you know just streamline the whole
process right and then um
so yeah they confiscated everything took
my safe
and he gave me a card and i had guns at
the house they didn't take none of my
guns
i had my concealed weapons license i had
firearms all over the house they didn't
take any of them
i had weed at the house and this is
south carolina south carolina
illegal at that time marijuana legal in
south carolina [ __ ] yeah still they
don't have they don't they're [ __ ]
hicks over there they ain't illegal
that's the bible baby yeah that's the
[ __ ] uh
exactly he was falling deep in the bible
belt and um
yeah you said you were you you i mean
you had told me i remember you had said
they were anything we should know about
you said oh well i've got guns they were
like well we're not the atf and
yeah he's like we're not the atf and i
was like i got a little bit of weed too
he's like well
how much weed you got i was like well
it's not pounds it's a little bit
you know it means i smoke every day i
have been since i was you know
a little kid but yeah they didn't take
the weed
they left all my [ __ ] they left my
drugs and my guns they only wanted the
[ __ ]
the credit cards and all the equipment
and everything and then he gave me he
didn't arrest you they didn't arrest me
he gave me he gave me a business card
and he gave me a date on the
business card he said i need you to be
here on this date if not you're gonna
have a warrant for your rest
and so yeah i had to go to the secret
service uh
headquarters in columbia south carolina
and i walk into a room and there's this
long [ __ ] table
and i walk into this room and there's
like eight dudes sitting around the
table and in the middle of this table
they got all these screenshots
laid out in front of them of carter.su
[ __ ] all the carter forums i was on
they had screenshots of my posts
on the forums they had screenshots of
all my [ __ ]
uh people who i had been dealing with
they had screenshots of
um i see icq chats with me
so apparently i had been chatting with
the secret service
like they were buying cards from me what
yeah
yeah and i didn't know any of this and
they still couldn't [ __ ] track
they still couldn't find you well man i
was bulletproof yeah
whoa they still didn't arrest them and
they still didn't arrest me so i go down
there right so
i show up indicted yet do you see what
i'm saying like what are they trying to
do
well they have it they've got to put
together a case yeah so they're trying
to so they're trying to build their case
and this is just a theory of mine but
they said they thought they got the
little fish
and they were trying to get the big fish
there was a big fish though there was a
big fish
to get this thought in the eu in the
united states yeah
yeah which would be so they were using
you to build a k build a bigger
like a bigger they're hoping that i was
gonna
pop the lid off of some kind of big
conspiracy big you know big
multinational crime ring uh fraud you
know which i mean i was a part of but i
i didn't have the keys to unlock that
door
foreign